what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest
on the on the channel my little sister
amelia
hey i have these pens wait say hi hi she
is 12 years old
and today we are going to be reacting
to polo g party life before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
are you ready
all right so we got to interpret the
song
get ready to dance
how am i related to you again
[Music]
we live a party life turned up all night
enjoy the moment
you fought the hardest fight wipe tears
from your eyes it feel good don't
it take off and let your hair down when
hey
you all i see you here now okay what do
you think it's saying so far
i have no idea okay so he's telling
girls to let their hair down
relax okay i watch the gang ball they
all kept out and every claim
falls we don't care about party life all
night but chum lit
dancing under the starlight that's my
[ __ ] celine
[Music]
do you go to parties like that i'm 14.
aren't you 12.
when did you turn 14 this year buddy
um i've never been to a party like that
but i would like to be invited so polo g
if you're out there watching this video
i'm available
also hannah i have no life i sit in my
room for probably
unhealthy amounts during the day so i
don't know why you would assume i would
go to something like this
for my [ __ ] trying to make this one
night we won't forget
[Music]
okay so he's saying that they should
just party all night
enjoy the moment have a good time
okay what do you think of the song they
can live their life it's not my problem
you fought the hardest fight wipe tears
from your eyes it feel
good don't know uh take off
and let your head there's a goat down
[Music]
[ __ ] on are you trying to hurt me
yeah it's funny oh my gosh
i am funny
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] ain't no baby from the
get-go [ __ ] but he's still that [ __ ]
yo mama
do i have to answer this you already
know the answer
let's keep going
[Music]
[Music]
the old people
this is like a fun party
at my college we did not have parties
that were this cool
because you're hannah you're probably
never invited
i would have been my college was just
small
i'm sure that was the reason look it
okay i have i had hot friends it might
not have been for me but my friends were
good looking
yeah they were probably invited you
weren't
believing well i just didn't say
anything
okay what did you think what did you
think of the song
interesting to say still one to five i
have no idea i wasn't really listening
there was a whole point of this reaction
it was more making fun of you that was
the more fun part
that was the only reason you agreed to
do a video with me that's the only
reason i ever do anything with you what
is this
oh my god okay guys don't don't forget
to subscribe
ring that notification bell
oh my god the camera's not even on us
it's on me